in the world of appareon there is for a
lack of a better word a tier list of
sorts for the beings in the world at the
top is the archons who have since
perished underneath them is the
valorians and beneath them is the
tetrarchy including the vargo
the abyssians the neoc and the flame
blood today's video is going to be about
these
races there are a ton of sections within
the beast erie aberrant sibyssians
beasts constructs crimson wind black
tide etc
you get the point there is a bunch
within there i'll quickly summarize the
beasts craven and aberrants first then
go in more in depth on the neoc
abyssian's vargo crimson wind and the
dark tide the flame blood will not be
included as they simply just don't exist
in the current game at the time of
making this
possibly in a future dlc they might but
as of now they do not the plan is to go
over their ranks dig into their
backgrounds their motives policies and
statuses within their communities and
tribes as each race is unique in their
own way while there are three different
versions of the aberrants depending on
the realm they all form when outside
forces corrupt the ethereum in the realm
and it saturates with the soil and the
rocks because they are made of soil and
rock they are quite tough to fight
they're very slow so it's not
particularly hard they could just be a
nuisance at most
cravin like the aberrants also have
different appearances depending on their
location cravens are hypothesized to be
a parasite from cosmera when kosmera
devoured herself
the most basic type is the golden craven
drone but you'll on occasion see the
craven spawnling there's also
alternative versions of the kraven being
the lightning and volatile fire as well
as the earth
back in the day the craving waged the
takeover on a valorian monastery a man
by the name of em kion brought down a
lightning storm that destroyed not only
the craven but himself and any valorians
in the immediate vicinity the craven who
somehow lived had some elemental
qualities to them particularly in
lightning which carried on through the
generations the fire craven was actually
made by grieve sun steel who decided to
create them when he became exiled from
the valorian society
unfortunately the elemental fire made
the cravens explode after some time and
greaves was unsuccessful in creating an
army as only a few were alive at one
time the last summarized section
is the beast and the beasts are a bit
different as the term beast as used in
the codex is more of a general term used
to fit the more unimportant creatures
that exist in the world but aren't
affiliated with some sort of faction or
major species most of them have some
really unimportant backstory to them as
well like the razorback crab which
are just the beasts that hunt then packs
on the ocean floor but a couple ones are
notable like the raincore the sobeku and
theraks
the ringcore are simply just predatory
carnivores but after eating enough can
become an alpha ringor which is
drastically different in size power and
speed from its former version
so becca was one of the more dangerous
creatures in the water realm while risky
the abyssians would use them as guards
if they could lure them to the places
they needed and very similar to sobeku
is theriks
a wingless proto-dragon and just like
sobeku is also really good at guarding
things assuming you can get him there in
the first place the creatures and beasts
have always been on the bottom of the
food chain for quite some time with the
tetrarchy being right above them which
we're about to get into
right now starting off the tetrarchy
section is the crimson wind as they're
the first group we come across
in the game right at the beginning in
the tutorial section the crimson wind is
like a sub group of velourians who
pledge and swear oath to the blood's
sword
godsmiths made weapons for the valorians
and the crimson wind were no exception
they made weapons like the marksman's
rifle which was capable enough to pierce
through valor plates
their biggest and toughest ranks are the
judicator protector and defenders who
are the backbone of the group
all equipped with unique weapons either
sword shield or hammer
the honor guard of the crimson wind are
more the higher ups in the group and
they end up using pole arms as their
primary armament the two most notable
warriors that exist in the crimson wind
are excelsios and the high lord
excelsios is a frontline berserker who's
always looking for a fight and will only
hunt the toughest of velourians donned
in valor plates to prove his worth high
lord is just as powerful as excelsios
noted to have won various treasures
under macros's controls so
the crimson wind are a very tough
faction to be fighting against
accompanying the crimson wind in the
earth realm is the vargo they house
cannon fodder like the trolls who are
sterile creatures used by the vargos for
whatever they need
them for your typical vargo warriors are
the vargo strikers hardened warriors who
have been fighting since birth the
margals also have a mage and range users
the shaman healer and sorcerers are
those such mages the shaman uses poison
the healer heals his teammates and the
sorcerer uses energy magic at range
all of which are a part of the tribe
which helps connect them to the spirit
realm through sacraments the ranged
warriors start out as varkal rangers who
live among the rangers themselves away
from the tribe to train
after they prove their worth they could
become deep stalkers similar to the
ranged warriors but they used the magic
of the spirit realm to move to different
locations to get better vantage points
should either of these previously
mentioned warriors become veterans they
may be eligible for fatherhood and be
released for the war tribe to father
children
who will then afterward don a sword and
shield tasked with protecting the
younglings of the tribe
within the vargos comes the two toughest
champions the vargo champion and
zamora the vargo champion is a large
vargo warrior enhanced with ethereum
crystals inside his body
known as the personal guard of the
matrons and speaking of matrons we have
zebora who is the ex-arc of the vargo
tribes he was able to unite all the
vargo tribes on her macros
rule and since they made a deal she's
able to get all the possible ways of
ethereum in her realm as possible and
she can use that to build her army and
become the most powerful tribe that has
ever lived which is our true end goal
both the vargos and the crimson wind are
the first and arguably the easiest
factions but moving up the tower we are
in the water realm where the abyssians
lay the abyssian's lower ranked troops
consist of troops and builders the
builders are as it says
builders who construct the bases and
facilities for the tribe more wiser and
more obedient troops are considered the
spitters
they have poisonous glands that they
used to spit out of but because of those
glands it shortens their lifespan
because those projectiles they shoot are
cancerous in nature the lancer troop is
the most basic troop wielding only a
lancer which they use for the sacraments
the last three troops that exist in the
abyssian host
are the bonecrusher corruptor and medusa
bonecrushers are the toughest of the
tribe with loads of armor in hands that
can crush a valor plate with ease they
also feast on anything they find
savoring every single drop of bone
marrow from the enemy corrupters seek
power through ethereum and with the help
of magic can freeze their foes in place
medusa units were made to attract unwary
ship crews at first but this strategy
was quickly figured out so their main
job is to subdue captives and pray for
the rest of the abyssian army which is
used by their giant flashbang
the abyssians only really cared for
domination through any means necessary
while some factions are about spreading
their knowledge or tribe views the
abyssians always look to dominate the
species of aperion and
always try to be the top dog while not
affiliated with the abyssians you will
notice another group start to lurk in
this realm called the black tide put it
simply enough the black tide are macros
personal guards the lower rank consists
of the trapper conscript and mirror
the conscripts are the lowest of the low
and many aren't expected to live past
this stage and they're usually just
cannon fodder
the trappers are as they sound they use
traps and snares to support their
comrades by trapping the enemy
and the mirror troop can use the
spectral force to aid him in fights as
well as carrying a unique set of lancer
and sword
the higher ups on the list are the mage
users known as the ghost and the spectre
the ghosts are users of magical energy
at range and are apparently able to step
into kalsamera's dreams to become
invisible for a short time the spectres
are a subgroup of those ghosts who can
shoot more projectiles in a short time
frame and do more damage
the black tide's top soldiers are the
enforcer brute reaver and assassin all
of which wield melee weapons the
enforcer uses a lancer and can be
counted on to lead missions and carry
them out without question reavers are
slightly weaker wielding a larger sword
but to become more powerful they
typically do a mourning ritual which
drains them of their life force but in
exchange they gain a load of power
the assassins are the quickest warriors
in the group capable of killing targets
within seconds and then using smoke
bombs to cover their tracks and
disappear
they act like macross's eyes and ears
able to relay information to him
whenever needed
while the previously mentioned enforcer
is strong as is he is usually
accompanied with a buddy called the
brute
these are the muscle of the group and
are respected by everyone for just their
sheer strength and should anyone want to
test that
let's just say they won't be
participating in any raids anytime soon
the black dot is a deadly and dangerous
force in apparent if their numbers and
strength aren't intimidating enough you
also have to remember who their leader
is
our last faction is located in the air
room and while the air roam has the
black tide it also houses the neoc
falcon years before the war times were
used to help travelers go from place to
place and defend them but during war
they can use their exquisite eyesight
which can sight enemies from miles away
the adepts are the high priests of neoc
they're from all walks of life artisans
farmers or dew catchers all of whom who
picked up the mace and became part of
the warrior pack the wind carvers and
pulverizers are more like your upgraded
versions of the previous ranks
pulverizers carry conomos instead of
maces to overpower their opponent's
strength and leave them vulnerable
while wind carvers harness magical
powers to bring high winds and storms to
the battlefield
they believe this is how the gods appear
to them so they do this in a way in
theory so that they can fight side by
side with their gods and anything that
they come across
shield guardians are even tougher than
the previous mentioned troops
whose sole job is to protect the temples
and relics of their gods
their defense is absolutely unmatched
just shown off by how large their shield
is
and if that wasn't enough there is only
a select amount of warriors who will
become a part of the cult of feasts
should one become a part of them they
will gain immense power through non-stop
eating
these are the neoc summoners the reason
they're able to live is due to the
ritual that allows their body to
overcome the stress of excessive eating
the niak has always been an interesting
group it's a religious group made up of
many different types of people and
troops who just want to preserve their
faith and do what they believe is right
with in their own faith and belief these
are all the factions and godfall
currently in 2020
should there be a new faction i'll make
a future video covering that new faction
in depth just like this before we leave
though i do want to leave you off with
an interesting question
assuming all five of the factions we
just mentioned all fought one another at
the same time who would you think would
emerge victorious let me know what you
think in the comments down below
with that though thank you for watching
the video like to view if you do enjoy
subscribe for more future godfall
content and goodbye
[Music]
you